all right it is time for hatred mail
this week's hatred mail actually there's
something really important in this
week's hatred mail I want to talk about
but before we get to that quick reminder
about what hatred mail is the right of
the people to keep and bear hates shall
not be infringed Patriot mail written by
Patriots who hate David Pakman because
America and because freedom alright
let's get right into this week's hatred
mail and I'll play it and then there's
going to be I'm concerned about
something beyond just oh this is a
hatred and they say horrible things
let's take a listen to it
David is a Warren or but a gay shill
you've lied at least six times in this
video you've died in fact your
intelligence suggests that you were a
very conniving propagandist shill a
shill who is very much aware of what the
real truth is in of David's it aware for
sure LMFAO how the [ __ ] are you calling
Trump and he semantics he literally
moved the embassy to Israel so listen
okay it's a homophobic thing about Pete
Buddha jej Pete Buddha judge is a gay
man you're you know but you're a Buddha
gay chill or whatever number one I don't
support people who to judge when I
pointed out that he was soaring in the
polls nearly tripling his support over
the last few months I actually said and
and I don't support him now I don't know
the political leanings of this Hadrian
but I've seen more homophobic sort of
comments about Buddha judge from the
left then I'm comfortable with and you
know I don't support him I think he's a
centrist but it wouldn't even occur to
me to start nicknaming Pete Buddha jej
with anything that sort of jokes about
or ridicules the fact that he's a gay
man I get that we're gonna see that from
the right because the right is
homophobic in
and in the policy that they've advocated
for you know they don't want gay
marriage to be legal they often want it
to be illegal to fire someone for their
real or perceived sexual orientation we
know about all that stuff we on the left
should simply if we don't like Budaj
edge we should say here's this policy
and here's why I don't like it but I've
seen you know too many people on Twitter
and in different places do join in aims
for Pete Budaj edge that sometimes more
overtly sometimes less overtly are
making fun of the fact that he's a gay
man come on guys I I thought that we had
moved past that I could and the stuff
from the left that just say you don't
like his policy say you don't like him
as an individual that's actually fine -
it's okay not to like someone because
they just rub you the wrong way and you
say I'm supporting someone else that I
find more endearing or whatever the case
but the homophobic nicknames for Pete
Buddha judge are I expect it from the
right I'm disheartened when I see it
from the left let's just cut it out
remember that you can use the coupon
code Patriot for th8 e RI ot for zero to
save 40% off of the membership of your
choice at join pakman.com